these officers are killing black men and
feeling totally justified in doing so
it's to the point where they're not even
covering it it's blatant and we've had
enough right now you know I'm still
upset right I'm still very upset and
angry around these two recent grand
juries refusal to indict to who killed
unarmed black men selling cigarettes you
should be killed when Gardner was
brought down and screaming 11 times I
can't breathe who gets in trouble the
cameraman not the police the murderer
body cameras and police officers is not
going to fix the problem is Eric Gardner
chokehold and arrest was caught on
camera and I didn't do anything so lets
me get cameras on prosecutors and grand
jurors who go through this process then
I don't see how cameras are going to
work there has to be cameras and
transparency throughout this whole
system I'm hopeful today though we can
galvanize a community to show the nation
to show the world that there are some
serious human rights violations that are
having it right now this is the way to
go this is the start we have to just
push and fight for the change in the
impact and that's coming together all
colors and all races that's the impact
and that's the change and that's how we
pushed
this is the start right here
I